welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 12. yes
we're now halfway into part two of the
final season here and things are heating
up now's the time to join in and watch
so click the link in the description and
sign up for amc plus this episode begins
with more explanation on the fake
stephanie situation pamela milton's
assistant here is a smart nerdy type who
built her own off the books radio and
everything she and eugene talked about
was genuine she really did fall for him
over the radio there was one big lie
though her name is not stephanie that
was a fake name she really is max but
when her brother mercer found out oh
she's in trouble cause turns out
unauthorized communications with other
groups is like you know very illegal he
covered for her and lance hornsby took
over with the new fake stephanie one
other funny thing by the way about
mercer being max's brother how eugene in
his interview with him remember gave
like a really long speech about how he
was excited to lose his virginity to
stephanie which was his sister but
eugene's real messed up at the moment he
doesn't know what to believe so he runs
away for now he gets a scene sitting on
a park bench brooding and rosita comes
to give him a pep talk and long story
short at the end he goes back to see max
like hey girl i mean i guess you're the
one that i really liked sorry i didn't
realize fake stephanie wasn't you but
she was convincing and she seemed to
like me so i wasn't gonna argue max
isn't sure if she's gonna accept him now
but as these two get to talking they are
both very nerdy and um you know a great
match the other small plot this episode
is about king ezekiel's cancer surgery
carol pulled some strings with lance
hornsby to get him moved up the list and
at first he's all like i don't deserve
this there were other people waiting but
carol's like yo that whole list is
basically a lie rich and powerful people
skip it all the time you are a good
person you have this opportunity now to
live and do good with your life but now
the main plot this episode is governor
pamela milton coming to visit alexandria
the commonwealth has been true to their
word helping alexandria rebuild and it's
in much better shape now the big idea
here is to work out a deal where
alexandria would you know join the
commonwealth from afar and not just
alexandria they want to bring in the
other communities here too like
oceanside which we haven't seen in many
episodes but since they last spoke
oceanside changed their mind they're
backing out because maggie at the
hilltop is not accepting the deal but
back at hilltop it's in bad shape
because they have basically five people
here and have been trying to rebuild it
themselves maggie has so far refused to
accept any commonwealth help because you
know the implications of strings
attached lance hornsby talks to maggie
to make his pitch it's like hey this is
how we rebuild a real human civilization
i have a dream where the living have
reclaimed the whole earth and there's
settlements all over the place all
interconnected and working together and
sure i mean that sounds nice and when
some zombies break the barrier maggie
and her five people go out to fight him
off but the commonwealth stormtroopers
roll up and take him out so much faster
hilltop needs help and the commonwealth
seems genuine but maggie sees they're
this rigidly organized society with a
strong class system and for a decade now
maggie's been living in these small
tribal anarchist survivors communes it's
like yo the personal freedom we have in
these new communities i mean maybe
that's a better way to live no thanks
commonwealth i don't want your help now
pamela milton doesn't really care she's
like whatever hornsby this was your idea
anyway but lance hornsby really cares
what does he get out of it pamela milton
guesses at his motives if they brought
in these new communities way out here
lance hornsby could have been their new
governor and indeed lance hornsby really
wants to make this work he's in a bad
mood now he walks out into the woods
with his hilariously small pistol and
starts headshotting zombies oh snap he's
seeming a little bit psycho now we
thought he was better call saul but
maybe he's littlefinger and that's where
episode 12 comes to an end and that
marks the halfway point of part two of
this three-part final season things are
building to an intense second half now's
the time to join in and watch and the
best way to watch new episodes of the
walking dead is on amc plus stream each
new episode one week early and be the
first to find out how everything goes
down what's going on with the
commonwealth is it actually a good
community with some flaws or is it more
devious than we know what does lance
hornsby up to he seems genuine but i'm
now getting some serious villain vibes
from him and how will things go bad with
maggie leading to the maggie daryl
confrontation they teased in episode one
click the link in the description to
start your free trial of amc plus now
and join in for this epic second half
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and news
[Music]